Despicable Me was first released in 2010
and the directors never imagined it
would turn into such worldwide Obsession
from extra movies to accessories and
cosplays these are some of the most
popular characters on the planet wait
until you see what a real life grew
looks like don't forget to subscribe to
our Channel and give this video a big
thumbs up today we're checking out 10
Despicable Me characters in real life
Agnes let's start with the youngest of
the bunch you can't deny that Agnes is
one of the most adorable characters out
there we are sure many can relate to her
love for fluffy unicorns in the movie
The Character was voiced by Elsie Fisher
who was only seven years old while she
was working on the first movie Agnes is
an adorable six-year-old and the
youngest of the three sisters adopted by
group just like any other six-year-old
she has her sneaky ways of getting what
she wants Agnes tends to hold her breath
until you bring her whatever she asks
for isn't that just typical of children
her age she's also incredibly loving and
has no trouble befriending practically
anyone including the vicious dog even
Gru's reluctant to come close to Agnes
has dark hair that's put up in a
standing ponytail and denim overalls
you'd think it would be hard to look
like her in real life but this cutie is
rocking the Agnes look from the ponytail
and the red headband to the cute
overalls and a yellow shirt this child
could easily play a human version of
Agnes speaking of real life things from
Despicable Me Do you remember the book
sleepy kittens it's available for
purchase and it's the replica of the
book that Gru reads to the girls if you
have some Despicable Me fans in the
family then this is an absolute must
product to get yet Edith Edith is one of
those characters you instantly fall in
love with she refuses to show that she's
happy and gets a thrill from putting
herself in daring situations in the
movie she has some of the best
one-liners that are usually followed by
an eye roll Edith is a nine-year-old
girl with blue eyes and blonde hair she
always boards a pink beanie and is
dressed in an all pink outfit out of the
three sisters she's the one that's
usually the most pessimistic and doesn't
trust people straight away but we can't
help but to love her sarcastic
personality and watch as Gru eventually
wins over her heart Edith is voiced By
Dana Guyer who was 13 when the first
Despicable Me came on the big screen
Edith is a fun character to cosplay and
there are plenty of people out there
that manage to recreate a human version
of The Sassy nine-year-old check out
this girl who nailed the Edith look to
look like Edith all you need is a pink
beanie purple scan pink leggings and
some snow boots you'll also need to be
extremely daring and master the art of
eye rolling at adults and you'll be able
to recreate her look our next character
is the oldest of the three sisters and
the one that always has to keep everyone
calm she's smart and witty and she
doesn't put up with any nonsense Margot
Margot is the older sister everyone
wishes they could have she's very
protective of Agnes and Edith but she
also disapproves of Edith whenever she
misbehaves just like Edith she also has
a sarcastic sense of humor although
she's a bit more optimistic it took a
while for Gru to win her over and we
can't blame her for not trusting the
Minions from the beginning although
she's only 12 years old Margot is very
mature for her age she can easily
outsmart Gru as well as other characters
she is voiced by Miranda Cosgrove who is
better known for her role on iCarly to
look like Margot you have to have brown
hair and put it in a ponytail she is
often seen wearing a black T-shirt with
a white button shirt underneath a brown
jacket a plaid skirt and red sneakers
and don't forget about those glasses a
deviantART user who goes by the nickname
Pomo bernardis decided to cosplay as
Margot and she totally nailed it she
certainly did an amazing job at looking
like the older Despicable Me sister
cosplayers really can pull off just
about any look including the one we're
about to show you who's your favorite
character out of the three sisters is it
Agnes Margot or Edith or maybe it's our
next colorful lady Lucy Wilde Lucy Wilde
doesn't appear until the second
Despicable Me movie she's on a mission
to take Gru out and we don't mean out
for a date although that is what happens
after the two realize they are just
absolutely perfect for each other and
Edith Margot and Agnes get in new mother
she is voiced by The Talented and
hilarious Kristen Wiig Lucy is an
unusual character when it comes to her
looks and she easily stands out from the
crowd perhaps this is why it's so hard
to believe she's a secret agent in
Disguise she has bright orange hair and
can be seen wearing a long light blue
coat that doesn't fit in with the crowd
she owns ridiculous gadgets such as a
moose tranquilizer and a lipstick taser
which is probably why she's such a
perfect match for Gru her character is a
fun one to recreate and we love this
cosplayers version of Lucy her username
on deviantART is Madame Paradox cosplay
and she seriously nailed Lucy's look she
even managed to find the same white high
heels and they look absolutely gorgeous
so we now have four Despicable Me real
life characters and it's time to add a
couple of villains to this colorful mix
vector vector is the man with both
Direction and magnitude those were his
words of course not ours he's voiced by
Jason Siegel and he's one of those
characters you want to dislike but can't
vector's always trying to ruin Gru's
plans and most of the time he's
outsmarted by everyone including Agnes
Edith and Margot unlike Gru who had a
tough upbringing Vector is a spoiled
child who always gets what he wants he
has a funny look that's pretty hard to
recreate you'll never see him without
his orange suit glasses and his bowl
haircut although he's supposed to be a
villain Vector is a hilarious character
with plenty of scenes that will make you
laugh out loud remember the scene where
he shrinks the toilet with the shrink
ray and then the toilet had its revenge
his fabulous look got recreated in real
life by Sherry 81 a cosplayer from
Germany yup that's right she's a girl
and she was able to create a realistic
human version of vector we've come
covered a lot of cosplayers on our
Channel and we're starting to think that
cosplaying should be considered a
superpower we really want to know where
she got her outfit from because she
managed to look a million times better
than despicable Me's villains Miss
Hattie Miss Hattie is the only
Despicable Me character that no one has
ever decided to cosplay but today we'll
show you how you can easily recreate
Miss Hattie in real life in case you
can't remember who she is here's a quick
Lowdown of everything you need to know
about this Gloomy character she appears
in the first Despicable Me movie and she
runs the orphanage where Agnes Margot
and Edith stayed in before they got
adopted Miss Hattie is a parody of Miss
Hannigan from Annie so it's safe to say
she wasn't made to be a friendly
character here's what you'll need to
dress as Miss Hattie find a purple plaid
skirt that goes just slightly over your
knees grab a pink long-sleeve shirt by
high heels and put your hair up in a 60s
hairstyle after that make sure you hate
children and be really arrogant towards
people and you'll lazily become Miss
Hattie there is a character that could
very well be Miss Hattie's twin sister
as the resemblance is uncanny do you
remember Dolores Umbridge the strict
kitten loving professor of the defense
against the dark arts from Harry Potter
don't they totally look alike we can't
decide which one we dislike the most
grew and you can't leave out Gru a
self-proclaimed world's greatest villain
whose plan was to steal the moon just to
prove his point he has interesting
helpers but we'll tell you all about
them later Gru is brilliantly voiced by
Steve Carell and he is one of the most
interesting Despicable Me characters out
there we're sure you all know what he
looks like so here's a cosplayer that
managed to recreate a real-life version
of this ex-super villain we all know
Steve Carell is a funny guy but this
might be the best thing he's ever done
Steve decided to dress up his crew and
he managed to create the best cosplay
version ever he has the scarf the jacket
and he definitely has that Gru look
complete with a pointy nose he even
appeared on the Ellen show as Gru and
did a hilarious interview if there ever
is a Despicable Me character in real
life that deserves an award it's Steve
Carell what do you think you do if you
ever met the actual group he seems like
a funny character but what if he'd want
to freeze you with his Stingray maybe
that's why he needs our next character
who's the brain behind Gru's amazing
gadgets Dr nefario Dr nefario Charmed us
all with his amazing accent and cheerful
personality he's voiced by Russell Brand
and he's just fabulous he's grew his
so-called sidekick but really he just
likes to create different gadgets even
if they make no sense remember when he
created Boogie robots instead of cookie
robots or sent a minion floating up in
space he's a pretty special character
but a very fun one to recreate check out
this picture of the entire office
dressing up as Gru Dr nefario and the
minions those are some office goals
right there to look like Dr nefario
you'll need to put on your best goggles
a white doctor suit black boots black
gloves plaid pants and a portable mobile
ability scooter then you need to sound
like Russell Brand and start inventing
unique gadgets befriend someone that
looks like Gru and voila you're a
real-life doctor nefario some fan
theories state that Dr nefario was Gru's
father we never know the story of his
father but people suspected it might be
him as they share similar noses this
Theory got debunked with a picture of a
family tree that chose Gru's father's
name is Robert our next characters were
first introduced to the girls as his
cousins but they managed to become so
much more than that minions the minions
are some of the most popular characters
in the world they're loud they're
obnoxious and they have their very own
language that somehow makes sense even
though you don't really know what
they're saying although you can't find
the true versions of the minions in real
life because we're not yet sure what
kind of creature they are minion
costumes exist and these people are
putting them to good use but it's not
just people who love them minions check
out this dog and this cat rocking their
costume these yellow characters managed
to take over the whole world and they
even got their very own movie and a
video game we're sure they're not
stopping anytime soon in Despicable Me
we mainly see Dave Stuart Jerry Kevin
Mark Phil Carl and Josh some of the best
minion scenes include them laughing at
Josh printing his butt Dave getting
excited and accidentally firing a rocket
launcher and the scene from Despicable
Me 2 where Stuart and Dave laugh at
Silas Ram's Bottom's name what can we
say it's tough not to love these yellow
creatures they're voiced by the movie's
animator Pierre coffin who actually gave
boys to 899 different minion characters
to this day yes you heard that right
there are almost 1 000 minions out there
are you a fan of minions or are you
getting tired of the craze all the
Despicable Me characters together need a
tip out create quality family time spend
some time creating Despicable Me
costumes and convince your entire family
to play a character you think it's crazy
but this family did it and it looks
awesome and here they are all Despicable
Me real life characters in one single
picture who would have thought that you
could actually make a pretty impressive
family portrait if you dress up as the
popular movie franchise check it out
it's Agnes Edith Margo vector and of
course Gru we're very impressed by their
outfits and it seems like they really
paid attention to every single detail
made the characters come to life this
family portrait belongs to Annie who was
so set on creating costumes for her
children her husband even said he'll
shave his head to pose his Groove now
that's some real dedication right there
we are completely in love with this
portrait and out of all real life
characters we've shown you today this
one is our favorite the only things
they're missing are minions or doctor
Mario but since the two are rarely seen
outside the house it's safe to assume
they are still Somewhere Out There we
are already planning how we're going to
convince our families to dress up as
these characters and recreate hilarious
Despicable Me scenes we saw the PAW
Patrol Save the community of Adventure
Bay many times and now we should get
prepared to see them save our own world
with these real-life characters just
wait until you see the cute little
Marshall working as a firefighter if you
love puppies as much as we do don't
forget to like this video And subscribe
for more today we are showing you 10 Paw
Patrol dogs in real life Chase
this dog works as a police and traffic
cop dog and even got a job as a spy
since season two when an emergency
happens he wants to direct traffic so
everyone can safely go home and the
other pups can take care of those who
need help Chase can also track missing
animals or people with his spy gear and
bring them back to safety he is a
natural leader and takes Mission
seriously but he has to pay attention to
cats and Feathers because he's allergic
Chase also knows how to have fun when
he's not working and playfully compete
with his best friend Marshall but what
does he look like in real life Chase is
a German Shepherd puppy and he always
wears a deep blue outfit with a police
hat this breed is known for being very
obedient just like chase this is why
they often work as a guide dog for the
disabled a protective guard dog a search
Rescue Unit dog or a service dog for the
police K-9 now we understand why this
Paw Patrol dog takes his job seriously
the German Shepherds are also very
strong and courageous just like Chase
but that doesn't mean they can't have
fun when they're not working they are
very loyal and loving so we bet these
dogs like to spend a lot of time with
their families
Rubble
this member of the Paw Patrol is always
there to help with construction related
work if a building is damaged or if a
train track doesn't work properly he
will be there to fix it the youngest
member of the group is really playful he
loves to do all sorts of things except
maybe coming face to face with a spider
but that doesn't stop him from getting
dirty to do his job then he jumps in a
bath when he sees that he accomplished
his mission Rubble also knows everything
about skateboards and snowboards but
even if this puppy looks rough he is
completely the opposite he even tends to
be emotional sometimes and loves to take
care of little animals do you think that
the real-life Rubble will be as soft as
he is in the cartoon when we look at
these pretty eyes we know he is the
construction pup of the Paw Patrol is an
English bulldog and once again we never
see him without his yellow hard hat and
his collar even if this dog can look
intimidating because he is wide and
muscular he is actually friendly and
docile just like Rubble Bulldogs are
really playful and always try to seek
people out for attention there is
nothing that they enjoy more than taking
a nap with their owner but this time we
know that Rubble is much more active
than that when he has to work
Everest
here comes the lady who can say that the
cold never bothered her anyway she may
not be a Frozen queen but she is really
strong and independent just like her we
had the chance to meet Everest the snowy
mountain pup in season two she saved
Jake from falling off a snow clip and
quickly became a member of the Paw
Patrol
when there's an emergency she is always
there to clear snow from the roads
Everest can use her grappling hook to
get from place to place she's always
enthusiastic and hyperactive which helps
her performing rescues but what she
loves the most is probably her best
friend Jake as she hugs and licks him a
lot and we think that a real-life husky
perfectly represents her not only
because they are both adorable but also
because they have the same personality
the Husky is really alert and
intelligent just like Everest was when
we first saw her this is also what makes
them great companions when we want to
spend time outside during the winter and
even if Everest can handle the cold she
also has a warm heart huskies are known
to be really friendly gentle and
outgoing they are affectionate with
their family and Incredibly kid-friendly
dogs now we understand why everyone
loves the snowy mountain pups so much
Rocky
when the other pups are there to save
people and animals Rocky is here to save
the environment the recycling pup always
has something to solve all the problems
and he doesn't have to buy these gadgets
at the most high-tech store he just
picks up pieces that could be recycled
and uses them to create something better
there is no limit to the number of ideas
Rocky can have and the number of tools
inside his Pup Pack however he might not
be the best Eco puppy to protect the
ocean because he has a fear of water but
that doesn't stop him from accomplishing
his mission when he has something really
important to do
is the real life pup afraid of water too
when we see his fur we think that this
one must love to take a lot of baths
this gray Pomeranian is really
intelligent just like Rocky always knows
the smartest choice is saving the planet
before it's too late they are also both
active and extroverted which gives them
a chance to meet other dogs and tell
them what they can do to protect the
environment however we think that this
Pomeranian might not be into recycling
he just loves to make sure that we don't
waste any food by eating everything he
finds and as long as everyone makes an
effort we think that we're going to be
able to change the world for the best
tracker
just because you're small doesn't mean
you can't achieve great things we got
the chance to meet this dog in season
three making him the eighth Paw Patrol
Pup trucker loves playing outside and
discovering the wildlife this is why the
best place for him to live is in the
jungle away from the city he developed
amazing hearing skills that he now uses
to see if someone is in danger even if
his ears work perfectly tracker doesn't
trust his eyes as he is always afraid to
go in dark places but no matter what
this little dog is Really Brave and will
be able to face his fears when he has to
and this is one of the characteristics
that he shares with the real-life
Chihuahua they are both really
courageous quick and alert this tiny dog
often barks before a stranger knocks at
the door of their home because he heard
them coming this is what surprisingly
makes him one of the best Watch Dogs
recommended by experts so these two pups
both have the same special skill we
can't believe how much energy is hidden
in this Lively little dog for him there
is nothing better than being close to
people and spending time with his family
and we have no problem with that as we
would like to see tracker more often
Zuma
here comes the water rescuer of the Paw
Patrol Zuma loves anything related to
water he is always there to rescue sea
animals with his speed boat when there
is an underwater emergency and even when
he is not working Zuma has a lot of
energy to spend living in a Boathouse he
loves to dive into action and go surfing
another fun thing we like about him is
that he can't pronounce his R correctly
but laughter is the best medicine for
that and he knows it nothing can stop
this pup who is always ready for
adventure unfortunately his services are
not often required so we don't get the
chance to see him a lot this is why we
hope that this real life pup will get
more time on screen
this cute chocolate Labrador is already
wearing his orange water helmet and his
collar because he is ready for a new
mission if you ever owned a labrador you
know that this outgoing and agile dog
loves to play in the water and the mud
this means that they often get dirty and
have to take a lot of baths Zuma is laid
back and very calm so he is really
different from most Labradors but no
matter what they are both kind gentle
and trusting this is what makes them the
best family members no matter how old
you are sweetie
this little puppy seems too precious to
be part of the Paw Patrol but don't
underestimate her the real reason why
she can't be part of the team is that
she is a villain the pet of the princess
of barkingburg attempted to take over
the world sweetie fakes being nice when
she is around the princess but she is
actually very sneaky she is not afraid
of the Paw Patrol which makes her really
intimidating even when her plans fail
and that she is punished she puts the
blame on other animals sweetie isn't shy
to use her cuteness to get what she
wants and we think that we wouldn't be
able to resist when we see her beautiful
eyes this is why we are happy to know
that the real life sweetie is actually
really nice this Wes Highland white
terrier is really cute both on the
outside and on the inside this dog is
really courageous active and alert these
are all the characteristics you need to
be part of the Paw Patrol even though
this dog is independent she is also very
friendly with her family so you have
nothing to fear if you ever see a West
Highland white terrier we would love to
see a live action TV show with a nice
sweetie Maybe she could even become a
hero too
Apollo
here comes the super pup this is not a
dog like any other Apollo has the
ability to fly we don't get the chance
to see him a lot with the PAW Patrol but
he inspires everyone when they see him
on TV or in comic books Rubble is one of
his biggest fans and can even be seen
dressed up like him with his blue mask
yellow uniform and red cape even if he
seems Invincible the PAW Patrol one day
had to save Apollo and the bunnies from
the spider king this was the proof that
no one should be ashamed of asking for
help being together is what makes you
stronger unfortunately we haven't been
able to find a real life puppy who can
fly but the superpower of this American
White Shepherd puppy is probably being
extremely cute these dogs have a high
level of self-confidence and are really
courageous which explains why Apollo is
always there to save the world the
American shepherds are also really alert
fearless and eager which are three
important characteristics you need to
have to be a superhero however these
dogs are a little aloof so don't take it
personally if they like spending time
alone and don't have a lot of friends
they just love people in a different way
by making sure that they are safe just
like Apollo does
Skye
she was the favorite character of many
little girls until Everest joined the
PAW Patrol team Skye was the first
female member of the group and was
always there to keep an eye on the
emergencies from above using her pink
helicopter she also had a grappling hook
to transport people to safer places sky
is always fun to watch as no matter what
she does she does a graceful backflip
with a smile on her face she also loves
to play and participate in activities
with her friends however she can become
a little emotional mostly when an eagle
is around but she always achieves her
goal no matter what happens sky is what
we call a cockapoo a Cocker Spaniel and
poodle mix it is one of the first
designer dogs meaning that it is not a
pure breed dog just like the PAW Patrol
Pup this dog is very outgoing loving and
friendly the Cockapoo can never have too
many friends and every Adventure is a
new opportunity to have fun this is why
this breed is one of the reasons why
dogs are man's best friend this Cockapoo
is also very intelligent so we
understand where Skye's excellent
memorization skills come from this smart
pup is probably one of our favorite
characters and we would love to fly with
her on her helicopter
Marshall
last but not least here comes Marshall
the fire pup he is always there to check
for fires and extinguish them if
necessary he can also use his ladder if
a kitten is stuck in a tree and if
someone ever gets hurt they will be
happy to hear that Marshall is also a
medic pup he uses x-rays to make sure
that no one has any broken bones but
seems to love bandages a little too much
he is probably the funniest of them all
as he is silly and very clumsy he often
gets too excited and ends up saying that
he is okay after making a little mistake
but this is also what makes us laugh so
much so we forgive him every time you
have probably seen a Dalmatian working
with firefighters before just like this
little boy Marshall's clumsiness could
be explained by the fact that Dalmatians
are really energetic playful and active
with so much energy we understand why
they can get a little too excited
sometimes but they are also very
intelligent and athletic which explains
why they can work as Firehouse dogs they
are not only there to save people but
also to make the courageous firefighter
smile when they are on a break these
Puffs are always there there to save the
world one smile at a time are you a fan
of Teen Titans Go and cosplay well you
better stay tuned because we're about to
show you some of the most amazing Teen
Titans Go cosplay you have ever seen
stay tuned to see a record-breaking
cosplay costume that will blow your mind
if you love Teen Titans Go as much as we
do give this video a thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe to our Channel today
we're discussing 10 Teen Titans Go
characters in real life Beast Boy you'd
think it would be impossible for someone
to look even remotely similar to Beast
Boy right if you're not familiar with
the character here are a couple of
things you should know about this green
looking superhero as the name suggests
he's actually half a beast half a boy
and his real name is actually Garfield
Logan his Beast Boy superpower comes
from a young young age when he battled
an illness that could only be cured with
a serum that later transformed him into
a superhero pretty cool right Beast Boy
has green skin pretty normal looking
hair sharp teeth and a pink and black
superhero outfit and if he was an actual
human being this is probably what he'd
look like this cosplayer who's also a
dancer singer and a YouTuber is known as
Chris villain he did a fantastic job
looking like the Beast Boy from his blue
green looking hair to his outfit this is
probably the realest Beast Boy
impression you will ever see the only
downside of the human Beast Boy is that
he probably won't be able to shape-shift
into any animal on the planet the Beast
Boy is also best friends with the next
character on our list can you guess who
it is
cyborg every Beast Boy needs a best
friend like cyborg cyborg also known as
Victor Stone leads the life of a
superhero that's half cybernetic and
half man although this might seem
slightly unfortunate on the outside
cyborg actually seems quite fine with it
he's a fun and very outgoing character
who even manages to find a love interest
a Girl by the name of Sarah Sims he's
often seen as the protector of the whole
team and likes to keep his best friend
in check every once in a while sounds
like a pretty cool guy don't you think
wait until you see what cyborg would
look like in real life this cosplayer's
nickname is nightmage and he's known for
recreating large and mighty characters
and making them look even more powerful
in real life check out his amazing
transformation into a real-life cyborg
considering most cosplayers make their
own costumes this is a very impressive
piece of work he totally nailed Cyborg's
headpiece and perhaps made it look even
better than the actual cartoon version
you definitely wouldn't want to mess
with this guy when he's in his cyborg
cosplay would you it's almost hard to
believe that such a mighty looking human
machine is so friendly and protective
but that's precisely why Teen Titans
fans love cyborg Robin Teen Titans Go
wouldn't be the team they are without
their leader Robin known by his real
name Richard Grayson Robin is Batman's
BFF and he's nicknamed as the Boy Wonder
as the leader of Teen Titans Robin is
one of the bossiest characters on the
show but he does have a soft spot for
our next character can you guess who it
is cosplaying as Robin looks like it's a
lot of fun and this deviant art user
nicknamed takuya cosplay definitely
nailed looking like Robin Robin has
black hair a black and white mask to
cover his identity a yellow and blue
cape and a green and pink bodysuit with
a letter r on his chest this cosplayer
really did an amazing job and we bet he
had a lot of fun getting into Robin's
bossy character we're very impressed by
his belt which looks to be put together
by hand much like the rest of his outfit
throughout the DC Comics Universe Robin
gets replaced by several characters the
very first remains Richard Grayson
followed by Jason Todd Tim Drake
Stephanie Brown and Damian Wayne do you
have a favorite Robin ours is probably
Tim Drake also known as the Red Robin
and he even makes a slight appearance in
one of the Teen Titans Go episodes
Starfire and here's the girl Robin is
obsessively crushing on throughout the
team Teen Titans Go series Starfire's
story is quite impressive but to keep it
short she was a princess who then became
a slave then became a warrior and is now
known as a superhero this empowering
character shouldn't be underestimated
and she's one of the most beloved Teen
Titans Go characters yet this Starfire
cosplay belongs to a deviantART user
Queen caffeine and it's pretty spot on
the original Teen Titans Go Starfire has
long pink hair big green eyes and a
purple outfit and it looks like this
cosplayer managed to recreate Starfire
to a t what do you think would you add
something else Starfire is Robin's love
interest and she finally becomes his
girlfriend in the movie Teen Titans
trouble in Tokyo we're very impressed
this cosplayer was even able to recreate
Starfire's amazing eyes and put this
much attention to detail on her outfit
and this superhero princess doesn't only
have the looks She's also incredibly
powerful Starfire's power is energy
absorption energy blasts and she has a
pretty impressive combat skill but one
of her coolest Powers is being able to
learn a language through physical
contact Starfire learned English during
her romance with Robin Trigon Trigon is
a very powerful demon and the father of
another eye candy female character in
Teen Titans Go he has six eyes and he's
never up to no good his primary mission
is to make everything negative rule the
Teen Titan World sounds pretty intense
right while he might be one of the most
intense looking characters we have ever
seen but his Teen Titan version is kind
of cute if you're into that sort of
thing Trigon is strong and its powers
include superhuman strength regeneration
from absolutely nothing super speed
flight telekinesis and much more he's
definitely someone you don't want to
come across but he also does have a
weakness and it seems to be his very own
arrogance which blinds his Focus we bet
Trigon would be a fun character to
cosplay check out the human version of
Trigon on the right this guy made it
seem that recreating a demonic character
with horns six eyes and a red body is
super easy and he's even joined by the
real-life version of his daughter whom
we will talk about next Raven and here
she is one of the most popular
characters of the whole series do you
agree with this statement let us know in
the comments who you think deserves to
be the most popular Teen Titans
character Raven trigon's daughter is one
of the most interesting characters ever
she's trying to control the negativity
she got from her father but in the end
she's still on the team of these young
superheroes Raven often comes across as
sarcastic and mysterious but she stands
up for what she believes in and doesn't
give in to what her father wants to make
of her life her character is such a
popular role model you can find plenty
of raven-related cosplayers out there
but this is one of the best we've
discovered this cosplayer's nickname is
simrell and her cosplay as Raven went
viral on Reddit she looks perfect in her
mysterious blue cloak blue hair and a
black outfit check out this person that
got a very awesome looking Raven tattoo
what do you like or dislike about Raven
make sure you let us know in the
comments below we'd love to see your
opinion of this witty character that
made us laugh out loud with her sarcasm
blackfyre Beast Boy Cyborg Robin
Starfire and Raven are the main
characters of Teen Titans Go but now
let's have a look at some of the
characters who also deserve mention
blackfyre is Starfire's sister who
appears in the show for just a brief
moment but she is otherwise quite
present in the DC Comics World as her
name suggests Blackfire is a total
opposite from her sister she has long
dark purple hair and much darker
although her outfit is equally as cool
her powers include super strength
stamina durability and just like her
sister she can also project energy from
her hands for a character that doesn't
really have such good intentions as
Starfire does she sounds pretty cool in
fact she's so cool some people decided
to try out dressing up as blackfyre in
real life this deviantART user is called
chisai Kai and we believe her blackfyre
cosplay might just be the best one yet
check out that long purple hair and that
fancy outfit that could vary very well
look like the real deal blackfyre gets
her sister in trouble on a regular basis
if you're a fan of the series you
probably remember when she dressed up
Starfire as herself pretending she wants
to be her twin in reality this little
act got Starfire into huge trouble she
means business and so does this awesome
cosplayer Tara Tara briefly appears on a
Teen Titans Go episode called terrorized
that's similar to the original plot of
Teen Titans Tara is a Latin name for
land and this is why Tara holds powers
that allow her to control the Earth and
minerals she turns out to be a pretty
tough character in the DC Comics who's
even able to survive being immersed in
lava her storyline changes in every
series and during her brief appearance
in Teen Titans Go she pretends to be
romantically involved with Beast Boy to
get to the team's secret files her looks
make her a pretty fun character to
cosplay this cosplayer goes by the
nickname of Alice in the Tardis and she
did a fantastic job at portraying what
Tara might look like in real life Tara
has long blonde hair a black top yellow
shorts and brown boots in Teen Titans
Tara raises a lot of fan theories that
she was a very misunderstood character
who didn't know how to make friends and
just wanted a place to belong she's
probably one of the least favorite
characters on the show but that doesn't
mean that she doesn't have fans who want
to recreate her looks in real life well
Tara wasn't the only character people
have mixed feelings about ravager much
like Tara blackfyre and Batman ravenger
is just a minor character in Teen Titans
Go but she comes with such an iconic
look we just had to add her to this list
Avenger is one of our favorite
characters from the series and although
she has a minor part in Teen Titans Go
she's one of the most powerful
characters ever her real name is Rose
Wilson and she's a martial arts expert
who's also skilled at combat she has
many enhanced abilities that make her a
super soldier and she has the incredible
power of precognition which allows her
to predict the moves of her opponents
her Unique Look consists of long white
hair an eye patch covering one of her
eyes and an orange black and blue outfit
a cosplayer who goes by the name of
Megan Coffey did an amazing job at
recreating a real-life ravager check out
this excellent picture of her holding
Two Fire swords like a complete Pro what
do you think does this compare to the DC
Comics version ravager might not be a
very lovable character and while she
might not be on the good side she is
hilarious with her witty remarks and
sarcasm Batman all right all right we
can't talk about Teen Titans without
mentioning Batman can we he's very close
to Robin but he very briefly makes a few
appearances in Teen Titans Go one of the
episodes includes him getting pied in
the face by Robin Batman is a very
fascinating character and one of the
most popular DC comic superheroes ever
you can probably imagine how many Batman
cosplayers are out there right but
there's only one that was able to set an
incredible cosplay record the Guinness
Gamers Edition 2017 showed off a unique
Batman cosplay suit made by an Irish
special creature effects expert Julian
checkley this amazing suit consists of
23 brilliant gadgets that include video
screens projectors a UV lamp back cams
and more here's an even more epic fact
about this creation some of these
gadgets were made using a 3D printer how
awesome is that we bet there are a lot
of cosplayers out there who would love
to get their hands on this awesome suit
speaking of Batman did you know that
Batman is an actual city in Turkey it
was named after an ancient unit of
measure and had unfortunately nothing to
do with this iconic superhero some kids
just have a certain look about them kind
of like you've seen them before we found
10 kids who totally look like Disney
characters the last one on our list is
the most iconic Disney lookalike ever
stay tuned to find out who it is if you
like Disney as much as we do subscribe
to the things channel to get up to date
videos on all things Disney and click
the Thumbs Up Button if you liked this
video now here are 10 kids who totally
look like Disney characters linguine
from Ratatouille Ratatouille is a story
about a young dreamer who has high hopes
of becoming a chef someday the only
problem is he's a rat and rats aren't
usually welcome in restaurants
thankfully Remy has the help of an
up-and-coming cook by the name of
linguine together they create dishes
that Paris falls in love with all while
winning over the toughest critic in the
city well you're not going to believe
how much this kid looks exactly like
linguine from their hair to the nose to
the smile the resemblance is spot on
seriously if they ever make a
live-action version of this film they
should call this kid in for an audition
wrestle from up there has never been a
more unlikely pair than Russell and Mr
Fredrickson from the movie Up from the
beginning Mr Frederickson was grumpy and
distant from The Young Scouts but the
little guy was never swayed well and he
was pretty much stuck on the old man's
porch when the house took off with all
those balloons still the two helped each
other be better versions of themselves
all while saving a weird bird named
Kevin who was really a ladybird who had
a bunch of babies well if there was a
look-alike contest this kid totally
nailed it he even got the sash with all
all the merit badges sewn on flash from
zootopia who can forget flash he's the
sloth that Judy Hopps and Nick Wilde
needed to get information from at the
Department of Motor Vehicles side note
that's a hilarious commentary on the
pace over at the DMV this sloth is a
hilarious opposite to Judy's fast
talking high energy we really thought
her ears were going to explode when Nick
told flash that joke this is a totally
random reference but it's too funny not
to point out check out this girl who
looks almost identical to zootopia's
flash she has the same facial expression
and everything did someone just tell her
a joke hero from Big Hero 6. Big Hero 6
was an incredible film about the Triumph
of a boy genius and his Healthcare robot
after suffering the devastating loss of
his brother everyone loved the superhero
elements of this film and fans
absolutely adored Baymax it only makes
sense that young fans would want to look
like Hiro and maybe even invent like him
too enter this kid okay sure that hair
is probably a wig but look at the little
dude's face it looks like he was plucked
directly out of the movie and dropped
into the real world our question is can
this guy invent microbots too Jack Jack
from The Incredibles Jack Jack is making
a Big Splash in The Incredibles 2. for
such a little baby he sure does have a
lot of big Powers this kid can shoot
lasers out of his eyes turn into a heavy
lead ball spontaneously combust and turn
into the weird purple monster guy but
his biggest superpower has got to be
cuteness just look at him well as it
turns out a blogger from Utah has a baby
that looks exactly like Jack Jack right
down to the cute little hair point on
Top Danny Christensen said his
co-workers pointed this out and he
couldn't agree more Pinocchio alright we
know that this is a Halloween costume
and is intended to make a child look
like her favorite Disney character but
it's just too cute not to mention in
this list introducing the real live
version of Pinocchio this little girl
has the Hat the red circles on her
cheeks the big blue bow white gloves and
strings on her hands we'll admit anyone
can pick those things up at a costume
shop but what you can pick up is the
hair the blue eyes and the wide-eyed
expression of Wonder on her cute little
face Jiminy Cricket we've got to say
there are a lot of infants who look like
they're about 90 years old but we came
across one that actually looks like a
beloved Disney character they're both
short well dressed and hopeful about
life so who do you think this little guy
looks like we think he looks a lot like
Jiminy Cricket they even have a similar
expression on their faces do you think
this little dude is also going to
convince a puppet that he is its
conscience or maybe he's just a cute bow
tie wearing baby we found on the
internet Merida from Brave with her
unruly hair her strength and her
Defiance Merida won the hearts of young
girls all over the world she's a very
unique princess and way ahead of her
time she can shoot a bow and arrow and
she loves Adventure we found one girl
who really resembles this strong fiery
princess this young girl's mom couldn't
help but snap and share this pic of her
little girl she compared it side by side
to a picture of Merida with the caption
saying she thinks her daughter looks
like Merida from Brave we couldn't agree
more our question is just how good is
she with a bow and arrow Andy from Toy
Story Andy is the Beloved little boy
from The Toy Story movies who all the
toys long to be with forever all the
characters have his name written on the
bottom of their shoes Andy loves and
plays with the toys for years until it's
time for him to go to college then he
must decide what to do with his toys the
kid in this picture must have been told
a bunch of times that he looks like Andy
from Toy Story 3. otherwise he wouldn't
have posed in the exact same pose as
this Frame from the movie although the
kid looks a bit too Melancholy to be
Andy smile kid you've got a Woody and a
buzz doll Walt himself this has got to
be the best thing we've found on the
internet in a while and we spend a lot
of time on the internet this little
boy's mom posted a picture of him saying
that she told him he could be any Disney
character he wanted on their family trip
he chose the most iconic of them all
seriously give this kid a medal just
look at that determined hope-filled look
on this kid's face he is probably
inventing the theme park and movie
franchises of the future right now way
to go little guy we hope you accomplish
all your dreams if you have a
fascination with cartoons you're going
to love this video we've gathered up
some photos of a few of the most popular
and lovable cartoon animals and their
real life twins you'll definitely have
to do a double take when you see these
pictures just wait until we show you the
photo of the real life cast of 101
Dalmatians it's absolutely epic if
you're new to our Channel click the red
subscribe button and give this video a
big thumbs up today we're showing you 10
amazing photos of cartoon animals in
their real life version
Simba
as one of the top grossing Disney films
The Lion King has made over 300 billion
dollars at the box office there's a
reason why this film is popular and it
all has to do with its relatable
characters and its heartwarming
storyline everyone immediately fell in
love with Mufasa the strong playful and
kind-hearted father to Simba when Simba
was first born the baby cub had golden
brown hair and big black eyes he was
absolutely adorable don't you think what
would you think if we told you there was
a real life version of baby Simba well
guess what we found this picture of a
baby cub that looks a lot like the
Disney character this little lion not
only looks like Simba but we bet he
strong-willed energetic and curious too
the only thing missing is the real life
version of Mufasa Scar and Nala wouldn't
it be amazing to see The Lion King
recreated using real animals
we know it would probably never happen
since animals of the wild deserve to be
left unbothered in their natural
habitats but it's still fun to think of
what a real version of The Lion King
would be like don't you think
Scooby-Doo
the first episode of Scooby-Doo
premiered all the way back in 1969 even
though it has been decades since the
show was released the main character is
still as popular now as he was back then
the Animated Series has had several
spin-off shows made for TV movies and
feature films what makes Scooby our
favorite old buddy is his adorable voice
his loyalty and how protective he is of
his nephew Scrappy-Doo Scooby is the
type of dog we all wish we could have in
real life we're a little disappointed
that he's only a cartoon character how
about you well not so fast check out
this photo of a great day and that looks
a lot like Scooby he even has the
distinctive black spots on his fur and a
similar body shape just like the
animated character Great Danes are huge
dogs just like Scooby but they differ in
one major way Scooby sometimes gets
scared really easily especially when
there's a ghost or a monster lurking
around and Great Danes tend to be
courageous and they're never too it in
the face of danger but aside from those
differences these two are definitely
twinning
Dory and Marlon
the world didn't realize how much it was
absolutely in love with fish until the
2003 release of Finding Nemo in the
movie the fish dory helps Marlin on a
vast search through the ocean to find
his son Nemo Dory proved to be a good
companion on the journey although her
short-term memory loss stood in the way
of her remembering Nemo's name but her
optimism was infectious with her bright
blue color and yellow fins she
definitely stands out on the big screen
Marlin is a bit smaller than Dory but
that doesn't mean he's any less powerful
throughout the film Marlin finds the
strength and wisdom within himself to
search through the ocean and bring his
son back home with so many species of
fish in the world it's no surprise that
we found two that look exactly like
Dorian Marlin are you ready to see them
here they are this is an actual photo of
real fish inside an aquarium the big
blue one looks a lot like Dory and the
smaller one looks exactly like Marlin
Disney needs to hire these two for a
Finding Nemo live action remake ASAP
[Music]
Bambi and flower
can you believe it was back in 1942 when
the world was first introduced to Bambi
it didn't take long for Generation after
generation to fall head over heels in
love with the main character in the film
Bambi is in a bed of colorful flowers he
stumbles upon a skunk and he mistakes
him for a pretty flower he then gives
the skunk the name flower and along with
Thumper the three animals become instant
friends when flower Falls hard for a
female skunk named Miss skunk the two
become an item and have a child together
they decide to name their baby Bambi in
honor of the main character to name his
child after the deer is proof that these
two are truly BFFs this photo from the
film shows the moment when Bambi and
flower first made contact with each
other aren't they adorable now are you
ready to see the real life twins in
action voila this is a photo of an
actual deer getting up close and
personal with a skunk the deer looks so
much like the animated character from
its wide eyes and its coat of brown fur
with white spots what are your thoughts
on the real-life bambian flower
Gus
most people are afraid of mice unless
the mouse is Gus from the movie
Cinderella of course aside from Mickey
Mouse Gus is definitely one of the most
favorite mice in the history of cartoons
he's a bit tiny in size but that doesn't
mean he's lacking courage and
determination when Cinderella is
threatened by anyone guess who always
comes to her rescue it's Gus who never
hesitates to throw up his fists to fight
for the Disney princess's honor we just
love this photo of the animated
character he's doing what he does best
devouring some cheese and how could you
not love his two buck teeth they're
perfect for gnawing on his favorite
snack if you thought there could never
be a real life mouse that looked exactly
like Gus well think again we're about to
show you a picture that will make your
jaw drop are you ready let us introduce
you to the real life version of Gus he
may not be the same color as the Disney
character but check him out he looks so
sweet and his and he's going to town on
that piece of cheese
101 Dalmatians
calling all Disney fans cartoon
enthusiasts and animal lovers 101
Dalmatians contains all of these
elements and it really makes for an
awesome animated movie The Disney film
is all about a litter of puppies who
belong to their parents Pongo and
perdita sadly they're kidnapped by a
villain Cruella Deville in the film we
get to learn more about the
personalities of each dog perjita
exhibits many of the traits that are
found in human cartoon characters she's
classy elegant and very well spoken
she's definitely what we would call a
warrior and she's willing to do whatever
it takes to fight for her family Pongo
is the complete opposite he's very
playful a little bit Goofy and easy
going but together they make an awesome
pair and their intense love for their
puppies is undeniable now we're about to
show you our real life Pongo and perdita
are you ready
here they are these two Dalmatians look
so much like the Disney characters right
down to their collars one is decked out
in blue and the other dog is wearing a
red collar just like the two animated
characters what do you think are these
two dogs the carbon copies of Pongo and
perdita
Dumbo
this just might be one of the most
adorable pictures we've ever seen this
is a photo of Dumbo the high-flying
elephant with a childlike personality
the Disney character is innocent a bit
naive and very playful it's so easy to
fall in love with this character
especially when you see this photo of
him as a teeny tiny baby doesn't he look
so innocent we just want to pick him up
and cuddle with him forever if you've
been to the zoo or if you've gone on an
African safari you've probably seen a
real life baby elephant before but we
guarantee you've never seen one just as
cute as Dumbo until now this little
elephant is Dumbo's long lost twin don't
you think they have the same big floppy
ears and this real elephant seems to be
just as cheerful joyful and fun loving
as the animated character the only thing
missing from the real life Dumbo is his
magic feather to give him the ability to
fly
Bolt
both stole our hearts when he was first
revealed in his self-titled movie back
in 2008. in case you're not familiar
with his story we'll tell you a little
bit more about his background the Disney
character was adopted by Penny when he
was just a little puppy he grew up on a
TV set and he played the role of a
superhero puppy when he escaped from the
film set he soon realized that the
powers he thought he had weren't real
after all when it came to the design of
the character Disney animators may have
received inspiration from a breed of dog
called a polar bear white German
shepherd bolt has the same white glossy
coat of fur and the same pointy ears
that stand straight up on his head if
you're not convinced that bolt is truly
a German Shepherd just check out this
photo of his real life animal twin
looking at these two photos side by side
is more than enough proof that the pup
is actually living among us in the real
world even though they look almost
exactly alike who do you think is cuter
both or his real life animal twin
Timon and Pumbaa
can you name a more iconic Duo than
Timon and Pumbaa yeah neither can we
these characters from The Lion King made
us lol with their hilarious jokes every
time they appeared on the screen we knew
they were going to say something to make
us burst out into laughter when it comes
to their appearance Timon has the
typical features of a meerkat he has a
thin and lanky body a long tail and
various shades of brown fur on his body
Pumbaa on the other hand is a brownish
red warthog with a huge pink snout and
squinty eyes together this comedic team
of characters is set to appear in the
live-action remake of The Lion King
we're super anxious to see them on the
big screen but this photo of their
real-life twins will hold us over for
now look at how cute this warthog is
even though the meerkat appears to be
having a rough day he looks pretty
adorable too the real life Timon and
Pumbaa are far from best friends perhaps
they could bond over the fire flies in
the skies just like the movie characters
did do you like the cartoon characters
or the real life versions of Timon and
Pumbaa better react in the comments
section down below we can't wait to see
what you have to say
Winnie the Pooh
Winnie the Pooh has a very long history
that dates back to 1926. the world was
introduced to the bear through a story
written by an author named Alan
Alexander Milne many of the characters
in the original story were inspired by
real life people in the author's life
Christopher Robin whose BFF was named
after the author's son and while growing
up the author's son had a teddy bear
which he named Winnie the bear was named
after a real life bear that had been
adopted as a cub by a Canadian Soldier
during World War One okay that's enough
of this history lesson let's get into
the photos shall we this picture shows
Pooh and all of his adorable Glory he's
wearing his signature red shirt and
there's a purple butterfly just hanging
out on his nose now are you ready to see
the real life version of Winnie the Pooh
check him out this photo of a brown bear
with a butterfly on his nose looks a lot
like the drawing of you they almost have
the same expression on their faces don't
you think are you a huge Winnie the Pooh
fan
who lives in the pineapple under the sea
SpongeBob Squarepants get ready because
we're about to show you some of the best
examples of SpongeBob SquarePants
characters in real life SpongeBob had us
cracking up so make sure you watch this
video Until the End to see it now let's
explore SpongeBob SquarePants characters
and their real life lookalikes Mr Krabs
let's start with a character you can't
help but secretly love even though he
doesn't really have the nicest
intentions Eugene H Krabs also known as
Mr Krabs he's a greedy money obsessed
restaurant owner but even though he
loves money he avoids spending it as
much as possible his Krusty Krab
restaurant features the famous burger
called the Krabby Patty which often gets
questioned on his formula while we're at
it here's a real life Krabby Patty and
we bet you want to eat one right now
since Mr Krabs is an actual crab this is
what he'd look like in real life we can
definitely see the resemblance but Mr
Krabs has more look-alikes than just
animals the internet pointed out that
Clancy Brown who actually voices Mr
Krabs is the best real-life version of
this famous crab character we help
Clancy's not as greedy as Mr Krabs
though did you know that Clancy voiced
the character for 15 years Clancy even
joked that as he's getting older he
finds more and more similarities to his
crab character he still has a long way
to go before he starts developing claws
red skin and crab eyes he was also asked
about the secret crabby catty formula
but refuse to give any information on
what makes those Burgers so delicious he
really is the best real life version of
Mr Krabs Pearl crabs since we started
with Mr Krabs it's only fair to talk
about his daughter Pearl even though her
father refuses to spend his money Pearl
does that for him she doesn't believe in
Saving and prefers maxing out his credit
card we're not quite sure how Pearl
became Mr Krab's art in the first place
considering that she's a sperm whale
which means that her mother is probably
a whale too so here's what Pearl crabs
would look like as a real-life sperm
whale sperm whales can be up to 59 feet
long and weigh up to 45 tons which is
pretty impressive a sperm whale is the
same size as a school bus much like
Pearl sperm whales also have almost
Square shaped foreheads although they're
much more rounded and makes sense when
you see the size of the thing
unfortunately real life sperm whales
don't wear cheerleader outfits and they
don't have a heart symbol instead of
their nose this feature is only much
more highlighted with pearl Pearl is
voiced by Lori Allen who voiced several
minor characters in the movie Despicable
Me 2 Toy Story 3 and Inside Out Lori
herself doesn't really resemble Pearl
but she admitted she had an absolute
blast playing a bratty teenage whale
character
[Music]
if you want to watch just one more video
the premium is the platform where you
should go get early access to videos
from the things the taco the trendy the
richest and many other great channels in
one place with ad-free browsing click
this link to sign up for the premium and
get ready to binge watch videos from
your favorite channels
foreign
Mrs Puff
teaches the residents of Bikini Bottom
how to drive we've learned to stop
questioning why these characters Drive
actual cars underwater it's just
it's just a tune logic
Mrs Puff is a paranoid puffer fish who
absolutely low the SpongeBob don't blame
her he's her worst student and just
can't seem to pass his driving test
here's what a puffer fish looks like in
real life puffer fish inflate when they
want to run away often there's no actual
reason to do so perhaps this is why Mrs
Puff is such a paranoid character
they're also pretty toxic a single
puffer fish can take out 30 people there
are definite similarities between Mrs
Puffin and actual pufferfish but we
think there are two humans out there who
perfectly fit her description first is
Donald Trump who basically looks like
her
think the two share a similar haircut
and then there's the lips the face the
look the two really make a perfect match
and the second is the world's most
infamous dance teacher Abby Lee Miller
who is known for her main teacher role
on the hit TV series Dance Moms we're
sure Mrs Puff and Abby Lee would likely
have some interesting conversations
about their students although we're not
sure if Mrs Puff would actually be able
to handle the Savage that is Abby Lee
Miller
Gary the snail Gary made us all want to
rethink our domestic pet choices and go
for a snail instead he had similar
mannerisms to a cat and can sometimes
let out an odd meow this sea snail comes
with a unique pink shell which makes him
instantly recognizable a real-life Gary
the Snail would be a typical sea snail
with a hard shell this shell actually
protects them from their predators and
is so hard no one can actually really
bite through it they're free to move as
slowly as they want without ever being
in a life-threatening situation pretty
clever right while sea snails mainly
live in the ocean we also know of
regular snails like this scary look
alike which roam around the land snails
often are the symbol of laziness but
these little animals are pretty
determined think about it would you be
willing to move that slowly just to get
to your destination or would you just
give up Gary the snail is voiced by Tom
Kinney who is also the narrator of the
Powerpuff Girls as well as the actual
SpongeBob SquarePants
will talk about him later because this
part of the video is all about the cute
looking meowing Gary the sea snail this
real life Gary is part of the thing
called Snail art artists have used snail
shells as canvases for years and give
these slow-moving creatures a unique
makeover
Squidward Squidward and Mrs Puff have
one thing in common they both have a
strong dislike for SpongeBob and are too
tired of all his Shenanigans we feel you
we really do Squidward Q tentacles is
the cashier of Krusty Krab restaurant
and he absolutely hates his job although
you might think Squidward's is an actual
squid he's not he's been confirmed that
he's an octopus a lot of fans were blown
away by the statement but the fact was
actually confirmed by the Creator
himself back in 2005. two of his
tentacles were dropped to make it easier
to animate which also happened with
Ursula from The Little Mermaid
this is a real picture of what Squidward
would look like in real life this
illustration belongs to the website
breaking news and is definitely bringing
a different perspective to this grumpy
resident of Bikini Bottom did you know
that octopuses are actually super old
the first octopus fossils were
discovered to belong to animal that's
almost 300 million years old no wonder
Squidward so grumpy he's probably
experienced thousands of spongebob-like
creatures during his time Squidward is
voiced by Roger bumbass who's actually
the perfect human look-alike for the
scrumpy octopus Roger also voiced
several other additional characters in
some of your favorite cartoons Roger was
actually the one who evolved Squidward
into a sarcastic character you know
today Plankton Plankton is one of those
antagonists you just can't help but love
he's absolutely tiny but that doesn't
stop him from trying to find out the
secret formula behind those Krabby
Patties of course he always fails and we
love watching him come up with new ways
to trick the restaurant into giving him
the information he needs most people
dismiss the small creature because of
his height but he proves again and again
that your height should never stop you
from getting what you want Plankton
naturally doesn't have the kindest
looking features but neither does his
real-life version plankton in Greek
means Wanderer see planktons usually
vary in size but most aren't bigger than
an inch similar to our plankton in
SpongeBob these creatures are known to
turn light into energy and they're one
of the biggest food sources for other
much bigger sea creatures although
Plankton's looks in SpongeBob are much
more defined a c Plankton definitely has
some similar features including the
tentacles of course you will never see a
real life Plankton speak or even care
about things like Krabby Patties
Plankton is voiced by the director of
SpongeBob Mr Lawrence who also voiced
filbert turtle in Rocco's Modern Life
painty the pirate
you know we have to pay tribute to the
character that starts off the entire
show painted the pirate also known as
Captain starts off the theme song that
many can't get out of their heads once
you hear are you ready kids you just
have to sing along to the rest of the
theme song painty has appeared in every
single episode of the TV series we bet
SpongeBob fans can instantly recognize
him in any given situation but there are
also SpongeBob fans who get the extra
mile and recreate painty in real life
check out this incredibly awesome
cosplay of painty the pirate we can't
even imagine how many times this guy had
to sing the theme song we also
occasionally see Patchy the Pirate
replace painty but these two aren't the
same people while patches character
belongs to the voice actor of SpongeBob
painty is voiced by Patrick Piney
Patrick is known for voicing Cyclops and
Hercules and he was even the pizza
delivery guy in Toy Story we wonder if
he ever gets tired of being asked to
seeing the SpongeBob SquarePants theme
song but then again how could you ever
get tired of hearing the opening are you
ready kids I hi captain
you can't help but sing along
Sandy but let's go back to the main
characters of the show Sandy Cheeks is a
squirrel that somehow manages to live
underwater in her astronaut suit she has
a super heavy southern Texas accent and
she's one of the most intelligent and
outspoken characters on the show while
many others on our list tend to be naive
and don't really think things through
Sandy as a talented scientist who's very
athletic and fit it's highly uncommon
for a character to enjoy both Sports and
science but Sandy proved us all wrong
check out this totally hilarious
real-life Recreation of Sandy in the
world of Bikini Bottom
squirrels did you know that the squirrel
species grow up to be 36 inches but
their average size is only slightly
bigger than a teacup they bury food in
the fall to prepare for The Long Winter
but the truth is they bury so much of it
they can barely recover all their treats
we don't really see Sandy act like a
typical squirrel though she's best
friends with SpongeBob and somewhat
tolerates Patrick but when you're as
intelligent as Sandy characters like
Patrick do actually get on your nerves
Sandy is voiced By Carolyn Lawrence
who's still best known for her iconic
role as the intelligent squirrel who
hangs out with a sponge
Patrick
so let's take a moment to talk about the
character that can sometimes make you
pull out your own hair as you watch him
solve problems Patrick's questionable
intelligence often brings the fun
element to the show but sometimes we
just can't help but worry about his
well-being this pink cartoon starfish is
lazy and his stupidity never goes
unnoticed but at the same time he's the
one that brings all the fun to the show
Patrick is actually a perfect
representation of a real-life starfish
and they have no brain no blood and can
weigh up to 11 pounds they basically
don't do much during their lifetime but
can easily live up to 35 years which is
pretty impressive so in a sense if a
starfish could speak we imagine it would
have the same characteristics as the
wonderful Patrick Star we totally adore
his friendship with SpongeBob and
although the two sometimes do get into
fights Patrick will always come to him
for advice he's voiced by Bill fagerbaki
who voiced many other animated
characters but none were as fun as
Patrick while bill doesn't really look
anything like Patrick he was able to
truly bring out the best and sometimes
the worst out of this dim-witted
character but the real star of the show
is none other than Patrick's BFF
SpongeBob you either love him or you
really can't stand him SpongeBob is one
of the most unusual characters out there
and it's hard to believe that this show
was created by Marie biologist who for
some reason just wanted to bring life to
a funny SpongeBob character living in a
pineapple under the sea SpongeBob is one
of the most recognizable cartoon
characters out there and is known to be
Nickelodeon's main mascot he's childish
but at the same time he's an adult who
has a job and tries really hard to get
his driver's license
SpongeBob is a reminder to have some fun
in life whether you're a child or adult
as much as we love this hilarious sponge
looking like the actual character
SpongeBob was actually inspired by sea
sponges these creatures grow in all
shapes and sizes and can be up to six
feet long there is still an ongoing
debate whether the sponges are actually
plants or animals whatever they are
they're nowhere near as fun as SpongeBob
this yellow looking sponge with square
pants and funny personality really stole
our hearts and brought an interesting
twist to Nickelodeon's cartoons he's
voiced by Tom Kinney who also gave voice
to his pet snail Gary well real life
sponges aren't exactly fun to look at
Spongebob was able to give them a brand
new meeting what's your favorite
SpongeBob SquarePants character let us
know in the comments